vamos a comenzar con sudamérica hoy
sobre la penúltima fecha y le pregunto
entonces cuál es el panorama nosotros
estamos en colombia los colombianos
rezando por un milagro no juan así de
raúl para que la gente lo entienda aquí
en esta parte del mundo cuando hay este
tipo de eliminatorias el mundo se
paraliza aquí queda solamente dos fechas
en las eliminatorias de la conmebol para
el mundial y todavía hay dos plazas más
una de repechaje en disputa veamos
primero la clasificación después de 16
fechas brasil argentina lidera en esta
clasificación ambas ya tienen su boleto
a qatar tienen un partido menos ese
duelo directo que aún deben jugar por
ese aplazamiento que vimos en ese
partido en brasil los jugadores tercera
una selección que salvo catástrofe ya
está clasificada cuarta posición para
uruguay que revivió después de la salida
del profesor oscar washington tabárez
hasta aquí van las plazas de
clasificación directa el repechaje que
va luego así va a jugar contra un
representante de asia sería ahora mismo
para perú que es quien ocupa esa quinta
plaza chile es sexta y colombia séptima
bolivia paraguay y venezuela
lastimosamente para ti también raúl
meneses está ya eliminada en esa última
plaza pues sí lamentable pero pues nada
raro juan le voy por colombia ahora la
verdad es que quedó aquí leo y por
colombia me gusta vamos ahora a ver
entonces si así está la clasificación
cuáles son los partidos que tenemos para
hoy raúl hoy paraguay recibe a ecuador
uruguay se mide ante perú en montevideo
colombia se enfrenta a bolivia en
barranquilla y brasil juega contra chile
para mañana viernes argentina se ve las
caras contra venezuela en un partido en
el que la clasificación no está en juego
lo que está en juego para argentina es
disputarle a brasil es de primer lugar
de la clasificación bueno ahora sí se va
a poner interesante esta crónica de
deportes empecemos a entonces a echar el
número a ver las cuentas que se necesita
de cada selección para poder clasificar
al mundial de qatar pero volvamos a
empezar con ecuador- a la selección que
lo tiene más de cara para meterse en el
mundial como lo decíamos el ecuador
visita una paraguay que ya está
eliminada y necesita solamente un punto
de ecuador con empatar ante paraguay ya
estará en qatar regresaron mundial
porque no estuvieron la ciudad de rusia
2018 esta selección ya sabe qué en el
repechaje asegurado además aún incluso
perdiendo hoy pueden clasificar al
mundial si se dan otras combinaciones de
otra parte vamos a uruguay que es la
cuarta en la tabla ellos reciben a perú
como lo decimos y tienen que ganar a los
incas y esperar una derrota de chile en
brasil para clasificar hoy de manera
directa a la copa mundo juan tenemos una
fuerte audiencia en perú y en chile qué
opciones tienen entonces las elecciones
de esos países para poder ir a este
mundial ahora que entramos en un
territorio en donde tenemos que esperar
y además de otros resultados aquí
tenemos que sacar incluso más la
calculadora pero se asegura el repechaje
si gana uruguay en montevideo y chile a
su vez pierde ante brasil como estamos
viendo hay varias selecciones que están
muy pendientes de que chile no gane a
brasil en esa visita en esa partido que
juegan por fuera si la blanquirroja si
perú pierde contra uruguay solamente
podrían aspirar como máximo a ese
repechaje a esa quinta plaza a la quinta
plaza que como decimos se jugaría contra
el representante de asia chile por su
parte necesita al menos empatar en casa
de brasil para aspirar para seguir
aspirando al repechaje si chile pierde
hoy en brasil ya quedan oficialmente
eliminados de la eliminatoria al mundial
de qatar-2022 que chile saque puntos de
brasil es algo que se muestra muy
difícil no por chile-brasil lleva a una
racha increíble en estas eliminatorias
llevan 12 victorias y 3 empates no
conocen una derrota en lo que es todo
este proceso así que chile debe jugar el
partido de su vida para seguir con vidas
en esta comida en esta eliminatoria el
partido de la vida también tiene que
jugar colombia pero también depende de
factores externos que va a pasar hoy con
los cafeteros tienen realmente chance
están vivos hablando de la vida que
usted dice de las elecciones están vivos
raúl pero podemos decir que colombia
está agonizando para decirlo de una
manera sencilla en estas cuentas los
cafeteros deben ganar a bolivia hoy en
barranquilla para mantenerse con vida en
la eliminatoria un empate no los elimina
pero complica aún más sus opciones
aunque son la última selección con
posibilidades increíblemente colombia
sigue teniendo chances de clasificar de
manera directa al mundial deben ganar
ese partido contra bolivia hoy en
barranquilla deben ganar eso era la
próxima semana en ese partido como
visitante y esperar a muchas otras
combinaciones para meterse en ese
escenario que se muestra remoto de
clasificar de manera directa al mundial
de catarra juan y vamos a hablar por
supuesto de la concacaf a centroamérica
norteamérica y el caribe cómo está esta
tabla pero la que hay tres cupos de
plaza directo de plaza de recta más uno
de repechaje canadá es líder invicto del
octagonal final con 25 puntos lo sigue
eeuu y méxico y hasta aquí va la
clasificación directa para ma en ese
momento será el combinado que iría al
repechaje contra un representante de
oceanía
costa rica y hasta el salvador aún
tienen opciones de clasificación para la
tabla de la concacaf y exactamente
seguimos hablando de la concacaf y qué
partidos podemos esperar para hoy en
todo este bloque hoy tenemos cuatro
partidos y después de esta fecha quedan
otros dos más costa rica recibe a canadá
méjico se enfrenta a eeuu panamá juega
contra honduras y jamaica se mide a el
salvador canadá pudiera ser juan la gran
protagonista de esta fecha así así ese
es el país llamado hacer historia que
nada solamente ha clasificado a un
mundial fue para la copa mundo de 1986
hoy siguen una costa rica se meten en
qatar 2022 además si empatan y también
empata panamá y eeuu como estamos viendo
aquí también clasificarían a ese mundial
una selección la de canadá la que ya
tiene asegurado el repechaje para el
mundial de qatar-2022 en repechaje que
jugarían contra el equipo su centro
américa contra el equipo de oceanía